Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
La palma de cera
es el árbol nacional de Colombia.
Es una especie endémica,
una especie muy amenazada.
Y durante los últimos años
ha tenido mucha atención
por parte de los conservacionistas,
entre los cuales me encuentro.
No con mucho éxito desafortunadamente.
Pero las investigaciones que se han hecho
sobre la palma este año
revelaron algo interesante:
Algunos ejemplares son transexuales.
Y les aseguro que
no tuve nada que ver con ello.
(Risas)
El cambio de sexo y de género
se ha reportado regularmente en la ciencia,
cada vez más.
Sin embargo,
mucha gente utiliza el argumento
de la falta de naturalidad
en la comunidad LGBT
para cuestionar
y criticar su existencia, incluso.
En muchos casos eso redunda en violencia,
en discriminación, hacia las personas LGBT.
En la naturaleza, en contraste,
encontramos especies
que parecen andar todo el tiempo
en desfiles de orgullo gay.
(Risas)
Como estas ranitas.
Despliegan una cantidad
de colores, de formas,
que incluso ponen en riesgo
su existencia ante los depredadores.
Estas ranitas usan esa estrategia
como un mecanismo fundamental
de adaptación, de innovación,
para la evolución.
Nos preguntamos entonces
si existe alguna relación
entre la construcción
de identidad sexual y de género
entre los seres humanos
con la biodiversidad.
¿Cómo se construye realmente
esa identidad entre las personas?
Y ¿cómo se construye
en las demás especies?
Proviniendo de la literatura,
la teoría queer nos sugiere
que la identidad sexual
se construye en la interacción
que tienen los personajes
que comparten una narración.
Todos nosotros,
las otras especies del mundo
compartimos esa gran historia
que es la vida, gracias al ADN.
Estamos en el mismo cuento.
La teoría queer también destaca
lo raro, destaca lo ambiguo,
destaca lo excéntrico como cualidades
que nos van a ayudar a adaptarnos
a los retos del cambio climático,
a los retos de las nuevas tecnologías,
a esa gran transformación que
el mundo está sufriendo en estos tiempos.
La teoría queer, además,
nos dice que es el cuerpo
el que se va a poner en juego cada vez más
para poder asumir
esa variación tan importante
que requerimos en la adaptación.
El cuerpo se desarrolla
y construye identidad
dependiendo entonces
de con quién se relaciona,
de cómo vive en un territorio determinado.
Por ejemplo, los pueblos awá,
emberá del Pacífico colombiano
viven en unas selvas ecuatoriales
tremendamente húmedas.
Llueve hasta 8000 mm al año,
con una temperatura media de 30 a 35 ºC.
Se imaginan a sí mismos
como descendientes de las lianas,
de las raíces de las epífitas
--las orquídeas que crecen
en los árboles--.
Ellos construyen su identidad
a partir de su manera de relacionarse
con las plantas y con los animales.
Desarrollan identidades híbridas.
En cambio, nosotros que ya vivimos
en una civilización occidental y moderna,
optamos por romper nuestros vínculos
con esa naturaleza, con esos árboles,
con ese bosque, con esos animales.
Y estudiar, poner en la distancia,
esos objetos que la constituyen.
Cada vez que acudimos
a entender esa relación
fragmentamos el ecosistema en pedacitos.
Y proyectamos sobre esos pedacitos
toda la fuerza de nuestra razón.
Casi que encandilando el objeto.
Con lo cual, indudablemente
ganamos precisión,
pero perdemos en visión.
Rompemos la conexión que hay
entre todos los seres
y construimos una visión distinta
a partir de esos pedacitos
con los que ensamblamos
una colección de museo
con los que ensamblamos un catálogo.
Por supuesto los catálogos
nos dicen mucho de cómo es el mundo.
Pero es un mundo
que ya no tiene identidad de género,
que ya no tiene identidad sexual.
Es un catálogo que además se puede
reorganizar de acuerdo a muchas lógicas.
Cada quien le puede dar sentido
a la manera en que se organiza.
Puede servir de base
para contar historias.
También puede servir de base
para construir un parque zoológico,
para construir un jardín botánico.
En fin, también nos ayuda
a construir visiones de naturaleza.
Sin embargo, normalmente esas visiones
de naturaleza acaban agrupadas,
enmascaradas por el proceso
de agregación de todas las especies,
de verlo todo junto.
Y acabamos pensando que el mundo
y la naturaleza es una especie de brócoli,
de verde genérico.
Y fíjense Uds. cómo a veces
las políticas ambientales
están constituidas
por la conservación del verde
sin realmente entender que
lo que está pasando en el mundo
es un constante arreglo y cambio de
las especies que se están relacionando
y están evolucionando activamente.
Realmente ese ejercicio
de simplificación del mundo,
de distanciamiento del mundo,
ha llevado a que construyamos
una perspectiva
tremendamente homogénea del mismo.
Una perspectiva en la cual la diversidad
y la diversidad de género
y la diversidad sexual,
no son importantes.
Un mundo en el cual las relaciones
entre las especies
y entre nosotros y la naturaleza
cambia sustancialmente de sentido.
Por eso mismo creo que es tiempo
de reincorporar, rescatar,
la diversidad sexual y de género
en nuestras visiones de la naturaleza.
Es tiempo de rechazar la homogeneidad
y de darle un espacio
a la diversidad de verdad,
a la diversidad que está representada
por las interacciones
entre todas las personas.
Es tiempo de construir una versión
más gozosa, más divertida,
y más bonita de la naturaleza.
Porque no hay nada más queer
que la naturaleza.
(Vítores)(Aplausos)